thank you very much so thank you very
much for inviting me this is a wonderful
workshop and today I'm gonna talk about
a very recent work recent paper we
completed on a variation in the Quality
Framework for network games and this is
joint with a brilliant researcher
Francesca Perez I was sitting there
she's a postdoc in my group at Leeds and
I'm from Department of EDS so network
games
I guess the connection to the workshop
is the network games it's a general
framework for analyzing social economic
or less a societal networks also those
with an infrastructure underneath and
the goal of the paper is to show that
the variation in inequalities basically
this approach is a unified systematic
and powerful approach for analyzing
networked games and I'll try to show you
basically how this unifies many of the
existing results in the literature so
just to motivate in many social and
economic settings clearly who interacts
with whom matters for example if you
think about the decision of an
individual to buy a product adopt new
innovations ideas behaviors our decision
to smoke for instance or uniform
opinions contribute to public goods is
affected by the actions of our friends
as well as acquaintances and similarly
in the context of competition if you
think about firms investments these are
also affected by other firms producing
substitute or complementary goods and
sort of over the past decade or two
network games have emerged as a powerful
framework for analyzing such
interactions where by agents interact
with each other according to an
underlying network represented by a
graph and the difference of this game
model from general games is that players
payoff does not depend on the strategies
of everyone but only of his own action
and an aggregate of actions of those in
the neighborhood so somehow this is sort
of summary statistic and it only depends
on the actions in the neighborhood and
because of this aggregate property
sometimes these games are also referred
to as
for aggregates of games in some of the
literature's but it's the same idea and
the major interest of this literature
has been have the underlying
connectivity or the patterns of in their
interactions have sparse this network is
how clustered this network is in shaping
the equilibrium outcomes and if you look
at the literature there's a large
literature and this is you know in
several different strands I'm trying to
point out these this is mostly in the
economics for tractability reasons much
of this work focuses on special gates
and what do I mean by that games with
specific structure they assume that the
cost functions are quadratic scalar
they're non-negative and mostly
symmetric networks meaning that I
influence Franchesca the same machine
influences me and moreover the focus has
been this is also an important point has
been on specific types of interactions
so games with strategic complements or
games with strategic substitutes and
what that means is basically high-level
best response of an agent is increasing
in other agent strategies in the case of
complements so the strategies move in
the same direction or decreases in other
strategies in the case of substitutes
and there's the large number of papers
here I just put sort of some of the
seminal papers in these two different
settings just to put it into context I
think I just want to give you an example
think about where the complements may be
investments in new technologies let's
say farmers invest in a new crop making
it more productive that increases other
farmers also adopting this new tech new
crop or new technology and for the case
of substitutes a sort of an example that
sort of rings a bell is the context of
security if a set of computer networks
or systems invest more in security that
makes an attack being successful less
likely and therefore discouraging others
to make similar investments so that's
the case of substitutes but if you look
at a lot of economic interactions or
strategic interactions we don't see this
substitution and complement both effects
are present and moreover another
important thing to notice in this
literature is within these assumptions
worx relied on desperate techniques
mostly through some potential game
potential function characterization but
then led to different characterizations
of equilibrium some some like if you
look at Pallister they say in the
context of complements we show that the
equilibrium depends on the maximum eigen
value of the adjacency matrix if you
look at the substitutes this is the this
2014 Econometrica paper they the main
point of the paper is we show that the
property of the network that matters is
the minimum eigen value and it's not
completely clear why we get conditions
on lambda max conditions on lambda min
in these different settings so the goal
of the paper is to use variation in
equality reformulation of the nash to
come up with a unified way of
understanding these properties and the
properties I'm gonna focus on are mostly
existence and uniqueness but I'll say
something about convergence of best
response dynamics and comparative
statics at the end so we'll see that our
framework allows study of general
strategic interactions I don't need to
restrict myself necessarily to
compliments in substitute settings and I
will basically be able to through this
approach also cover cases where
strategies are multi-dimensional not
just single dimension as well as
constraints so you can think about
budget constraints or things like that
also embedded in this framework and I
think the sort of one sort of goal of
the paper is to provide a systematic
understanding of which of these spectral
properties matter when characterizing
equilibrium or when establishing
fundamental properties of equilibrium so
quickly related literature there's a
large literature on social and economic
networks but our paper is also clearly
related to the literature that used vis
in generic games there's the Rosen's
paper which is not quite you saying you
know this is the uniqueness the paper
that we use for establishing uniqueness
65 Econometrica paper it doesn't say it
uses the eyes but I'll argue that that's
what he does he uses really VI analysis
to establish this uniqueness property
there's also the seminal work of a kunai
and tank there's some recent paper which
is buried they from the title you don't
understand that this is actually what
they're doing it's about communication
gates that there's a lot of
results in that paper there's also
largely different aggregates of games
some of them in social science economics
mostly focusing on comparative statics
this monotonicity results some of them
thinking about distributed dynamics and
there's also a large literature on
traffic and equity economic models I
mean this is sort of Smith's VI
characterization of equilibria following
back Beckman mcguire winston but also
the famous there's the beautiful proof
that has been already referenced
multiple times of jose andreas and niko
using VI to characterize price of
anarchy results as well as Nagorny that
goes into comparative statics there's
also two recent papers that i would like
to highlight that looks at a VI approach
for study of special games scalar
symmetric substitute but these are also
looking at lambda min and my goal will
be to show that you know these different
lambda means lambda maxes and others can
emerge and see how we can relate those
conditions so let me dive in because I
have little time and I guess too much to
cover so I'll try to do the best to give
the main ideas across
so we consider a network game which is
defined by an agent's interacting over a
network represented by this mated
adjacency matrix g and g IJ is the
basically represents the influence of JS
action on i and we assume that this
graph is nice there's no self loops the
diagonals of this matrix is all 0 now
what is the game each agent i chooses a
strategy multi-dimensional strategy x i
in his feasible set this calligraphic x
i to minimize his cost ji i'm going to
be minimizing so francesca reminded me
ver engineer so we're gonna be
minimizing so costs so he basically
choose excite to minimize his cost which
depends on his own action remember when
i was saying but it's depends on as well
as this local aggravators di which is
basically aggregating actions of
everybody
according to this g IJ network structure
of course goal is to compute the best
response against this local against this
aggregate and we all know the Nash
equilibrium definition with the caveat
of we're minimizing here so you know
basically it says profile at
which no agent has incentive to deviate
no unilateral deviations can improve the
payoff me or you know reduce the cost in
this case I get very confused with its
cost business right so let's look at
quickly where we eyes come here this is
Nash equilibrium it's a fixed point we
know there are multiple reformulations
me I'm I will argue that the VI
reformulation is powerful and let's see
what V is variation inequalities the
definition general definition is that
x-bar solves a variation inequality of
operator F constraints a text if and
only if this weird condition holds f of
X bar inner product with X minus X bar
greater than or equal to 0 for all X and
I forget this condition all the time so
the way third of I remember which way
this inequality goes is immediately
related to optimization so if we think
of this F as the gradient of a convex
cost function it's not too hard to show
that this definition X bar being a
solution of a variation inequality is
nothing but X bar being a minimizer of
this cost function J why because if you
think about optimality conditions of
this problem this is just a stationarity
condition for optimizing a convex
function over a convex set and if you
forget this you just immediately draw
this picture which says that at the
optimum the gradient makes an angle
which is less than 90 degrees with every
feasible direction so that's basically
the equivalent condition for a convex
optimization problem so let me now put
it back with the gates will have the
following assumptions excited strategy
sets are closed convex for this talk
I'll assume boundedness the paper has no
boundedness assumption it makes
conditions a little bit more technical
but everything goes through and then we
assume komak city in your own strategy X
I and may assume that everything is
nicely smooth so that I can talk about
gradients and Hessians and if you
remember this sort of optimum optimum
attic condition and remember Nash
equilibrium was one whereby every agent
minimizes their own cost function with
respect to their own strategy right I
can basically put it together through
this game Jacobean whereby
stack up all the gradients of JIS with
respect to their own strategies and come
up with an equivalent definition of the
Nash equilibrium whereby it's a Nash
equilibrium if and only if X bar solves
this variation in equality defined
through this vector in which I'm it's a
very it's a weird vector it's a gradient
for each agent gradient of that agents
cost function with respect to his own X
I because that's what he's optimizing
then thing to notice I think that's
perhaps a key idea if I can't get
through everything is that this
formulation is valid even when this F is
not integral meaning that this allows us
to study games that are not potential
and that's sort of why we're able to
address mixed interactions because the
literature really goes through this
potential representation that does this
quadratic structure puts some you know
conditions on the science so that it's a
potential game this doesn't need that so
that's one key idea and the other thing
is to notice is that national government
properties let's not worry too much
about the constraints of depends on the
properties of this game Jacobian so
let's look at what that game Jacobian
looks like so the properties I'm going
to talk about are things like this sort
of three properties which are in
decreasing order of strength so I say
that F is strictly monotone if it
satisfies this condition and this is
exactly thinking about F and along this
direction X minus y it's increasing so
that's trick monotonicity this is an
inner product if you think about all the
blocks that you're adding for this inner
product and assume that one of them is
positive that's called a block P
function and then if you assume that one
of the components is positive that's a P
function so not remember this F is are
all n-dimensional because we're doing
multi-dimensional strategy sets so
that's why there's the difference
between these two if n was equal to 1
this is the same thing so this is an
inner product of summing up all those
terms and post sorry strict monotone C
requires that sum to be positive this
requires only that there exists one term
that's positive so clearly if it's
strictly monotone if the sum is positive
there
the block which is positive and if
there's a block which is positive then
there exists a component or which the
product is positive and if n is equal to
one this is it so why am i interested in
this well this is the result from 2003
if any of these conditions hold the
variation inequality and therefore the
game has a unique solution okay so as
you see these properties dictate whether
or not there exists an equilibrium there
exist a unique equilibrium and the proof
let me skip but this is exactly Rosen's
proof you say for those who know the
paper just let me quickly flash you get
two equilibria you put them you know
into variation in equality
characterization you manipulate you use
strict monotonicity to arrive at the
contradiction so what rosin does is a VI
proof so what what am I going to do with
this now here's the road map or the idea
of the paper I will drive sufficient
conditions for this game Jacobian
properties that I've just alluded to in
terms of the gradient of that game
Jacobian because they're easier to work
with and then I will basically look at
network games and I show that this
gradient has a nice decomposition for
network games whereby I can see the
olden affect others effect and network
because of those decomposition we can
derive sufficient conditions for the
properties of this gradient in terms of
the network as well as the cost function
and now from there we'll go to the
properties of F and then from there
we'll go to the properties of Nash so
that's that's what this paper does okay
let's dive in so what are sufficient
conditions in terms of the gradient
remember this was the properties we were
interested in strictly monotonicity
block P as well as P function so claim
is that let me start from here strict
monotonicity is equivalent to the
gradient being positive definite
equivalent no not necessarily
yeah good question yeah so I put here
some proof why this is true I don't
think we need to go through it this is a
result of FAQ and I am paying but just
quickly so that I think it's useful to
keep it in mind if you think about the
linear case with the gradient being a
strict monotonicity if you write it down
is nothing but a positive definiteness
condition and then similarly with P
function now I guess the hardest part of
this talk will be as well as the paper
to absorb is this so what is the
condition for block P function so let's
just before going into that stigma
notice T is this gradient matrix being
positive definite and P function for P
function we have a sufficient condition
that gradient of F is a P matrix and
there's a gazillion definitions for P
matrices the one that's useful for our
proofs is that positive definiteness is
that quadratic form being positive and P
matrix is weaker condition that only one
of them need to be positive okay but
there are other things that you can use
to check a P matrix you have you look at
principal minors you look at the
positive parts of the eigenvalues and so
on and so forth so block P function
that's what is the sufficient condition
for that and this paper actually has
that sufficient condition which says
that a matrix gamma which is related to
this gradient matrix should be a P
matrix this is very I think unintuitive
at first sight and this gamma is nothing
but you get this matrix a remember this
is multi-dimensional strategy sets
meaning at each you this consists of
blocks gradients with respect to X I
this is one block gradient of X ionic
straight is our blocks so what this
gamma does is for each block represent
this summary statistic of that n
dimensional object meaning for the
blocks on the diagonal it takes a lambda
min for the off diagonal takes the norm
and takes a minus and then you see this
for the first time you're like why very
unintuitive and I think this sort of
that's why we put this block but how it
relates to block P function to sort of
motivate this condition and this is the
following
remember block P function was this
inner product for an I to be positive so
if you write it down for this linear
case you can actually expand it out this
way and now you pull the diagonal and
off diagonals and then you come up with
mobile bonds for each of these terms so
this part you can lower bound because
it's a quadratic by lambda min and this
part you do cauchy-schwarz and then you
do this - of this AI J's to bound this
part and when you put the lambda mins
and - A's in to the matrix that actually
boils down to this object being a P
matrix so it's a technical object that
allows us to say when we establish a
sufficient condition for this N
dimensional structure I hope that is
clear so this is a little different than
the other two
but I mean I think it's an object that
allows us to get these sufficient
conditions for the N dimensional
strategy sets so okay let's now look at
the gradient of F in network games what
does it look like well F is this object
remember where I put all the gradients
of J is it respect to their own
components now if you take the gradient
of that you get this I put it here it's
a little bit hard to parse maybe but
it's just that you know you take that
object and you take a grade and then
what does it look like well you take J 1
X 1 you take X 1 X 2 xn you take J 2 X 2
X so on right and then the eyes remember
we're the aggregator so let's look at
what this looks like
diagonal blocks are take J I take the
Hessian and remembers the eye does not
have X I there were no self loops in our
function so it's only something that
depends on the first component and if
you look at the off diagonal blocks Xin
XJ what is that well that's the gradient
x i zi and then the gradient of the zi
with respect to XJ which is this g IJ so
when you put them together basically it
has this nice thick decomposition you
can write the gradient f in terms of
players own effect
how does my own action affect my payoff
how does this aggregate affect my payoff
because I'm in this network how does the
aggregate
take my payoff and what does the network
look like so this now will allow us to
isolate the effect of the network in
these properties okay so this is only
effect network effect in the network I
will skip this so this is what the
literature considers linear quadratic
games where you have this quadratic cost
puts conditions on these ki so you have
this best response monotone but
basically the gradient is simple there
and that's what they work with whereas
now we work with basically something
very similar similar decomposition but
does not need to be linear anymore okay
so now I'm gonna basically talk about
how we establish conditions for the
network games that establish or that
allows us to get these conditions okay
so let's look at the first one first
strictly monotone I want to establish
this game Jacobian to be strictly
monotone or equivalently the gradient to
be positive semi-definite remember the
gradient has this decomposition D plus K
times the network so I can do that by
just saying okay let me look at it
lambda min right positive definiteness
is basically the minimum eigen value
being positive and what does the minimum
eigen value look like for network games
it's the d of x plus this Jordan form
here and then this lambda min I can
bound it from below by minus the
spectral radius this is symmetric
because it's symmetric the spectral
radius is equal to this 2 norm now I can
decompose the 2 norm in to K and G and I
have a condition in terms of an effect
local effect and Network if I can
establish this being positive I have
that this operator is positive definite
and therefore it's strictly monotone
okay so basically this is what it is
motivated us can the consider conditions
of this form for Network Apes own affect
others effect and something about the
network W of G and what could this
something be well it could be G - it
could be lambda min it could be G
infinity and the minute you put it these
sufficient conditions in one page you
get essentially everything in the
literature you get that for from the
first condition
the results of Pallister without
requiring any strategic compliments
assumption you get the condition
baguettes this ìlook result for
substitutes it generalizes it it doesn't
have to be the specific functional form
they're considering and this condition
sees new nobody considered G infinity
before but we thought it's reasonable
why because G infinity is the maximum
Rosa what are the rules
the effect of others on me so this is
maximum of that is maximum influence
that an agent can have so a condition of
that sort also makes sense to study okay
so I'm doing not well and with time I
knew this so the other question that
sort of we try to understand what we
have not three conditions how Rd is
related to each other which one is more
general which one is five minutes okay
I'm good okay so for symmetric networks
actually I'll skip some of the proofs
I'm happy to you know talk or send the
slides later for symmetric networks the
interesting thing is the condition which
is both general meaning it covers the
most you know for the same network most
set of payoff functions is the one
that's given in terms of min right so
with two you can establish positivity in
a narrower class of games than in min so
this is sort of one way of relating the
conditions in the literature but this is
for symmetric networks for asymmetric
networks you can't define lambda min
right we don't have that the spectrum is
real but you can still talk about G
twins infinity and one can show that
actually in some games you get the
property through g2 sorry alpha 2 and in
some games you get it through alpha
infinity so this allows you to get sort
of a way of getting these uniqueness
existence results for a larger class of
games that has been studied before but
though I think important point is to
realize that conditions come from this
decomposition of the network game
gradient and takes this form of you know
own affect others effect on network so
that's the lesson and now let me just do
probably
or two things the next thing is to fill
out this table put your alpha 2 alpha
infinity and alpha min and see which one
actually establishes these different
conditions trig monotone SDP function
and block P function I've already showed
that if alpha 2 is positive we get
streak monotonicity the next thing is to
look at these two conditions and then
it's not too hard to show that those
remember those were more general alpha
meaning particularly was more general
that doesn't establish strict
monotonicity for strip monotonicity you
need to lower about this object and
sufficient condition for that is to
bound both G infinity and G 1 so if you
just establish that one of them is small
it's not enough to say that the operator
is strictly monotone and you can this is
very vague intuition but you can come up
with examples that shows that these are
not enough to establish strict
monotonicity and then we have sort of
these other conditions which I won't
have time to prove but it's not too hard
to show that now if you look at this
particular property you can show that 2
in infinities ya achieve that but the
mean is still not sufficient to
establish this property I'm gonna skip
the proofs the proofs are nice what I'm
gonna skip I don't have time so if you
look at the weakest condition which is
the gradient being a P function now you
can show that indeed this alpha min
condition which is the most general for
the networks is enough to establish not
strict honesty not this condition but a
P function property which is enough to
say that this game has a unique
equilibrium okay so this is this was the
goal of the paper race we fill out this
table find conditions for in terms of
the network and other properties of the
game to say that when do we have the
properties of the game Jacobian to
establish properties of the Nash
equilibrium itself now let me starting
from this table tell you a couple of
things about the Nash properties that we
can establish here so I've already shown
you the results from VI fuckiní Ampang
which says that if you have any of these
conditions you have existence and
uniqueness so it turns out that any of
our conditions give us existence a
uniqueness
second this papers qatari that I
mentioned looks at asynchronous best
response dynamics and shows basically
that this gamma is a P matrix condition
is a sufficient condition to get
convergence for this asynchronous best
response dynamics so looking at our
table it shows that alpha 2 and alpha
infinity which is enough to establish
gamma is the P matrix gets us the
convergence and this one isn't and let
me tell you one thing which is very
non-intuitive still I don't understand
you would think that strong strict or
strong monotonicity is enough to
establish best response dynamics
convergence it isn't you can construct
contour examples that says that strick
monotonicity does not allow you to
establish block contraction of that
operator so the relevant property is
that gamma being a P matrix and that is
something interesting to look at a
little bit more I'm not sure I
understand that very well and the other
things are basically how so if you look
at this Lipschitz continuity sort of how
does you know suppose you have a
parametric game you change you introduce
a shock to the game and you want to
understand how the equilibrium moves so
this is the comparative statics results
I'd rate continuous Lipschitz continuous
arrow you know how does the equilibria
move strong monotonicity pays enough to
establish Lipschitz continuity we showed
in the paper that block p function is
also sufficient to establish Lipschitz
continuity so that allows us to fill
this table with these different
conditions and different properties of
the Nash I don't have time to talk about
this what I wanted to flesh slide to
attract your attention you can also use
these conditions to establish beyond
Lipschitz continue to some
differentiability properties sort of
locally how does your equilibrium move
when you introduce shocks to the system
these are basically interesting in the
context of cascade systemic risk
questions and whatnot and what we can
show is that basically for a generic
game with parameters or shocks this
strong monotonicity allows you to
explicitly write down the change in the
equilibrium in terms of the network
structure constraints everything and it
allows you to study quiz questions like
suppose you have a shock to the system
you can target one of the agents so that
you know you minimize the effect of the
aggregate level shock which agent are
you going to target it turns out if you
use that formula immediately the agent
that pops out is the so-called key
player centrality which is different
from the Bonacci centrality that
everybody uses so you can use these
conditions to be able to do such sort of
address such questions so with that let
me stop I'm glad I finished on almost
time so the goal is basically use v is
to develop an understanding I think it's
a very powerful approach so all of these
games are studied through potential
functions we don't need that so that's
the point of this of this paper I
mentioned in the paper we don't use
compactness that basically automatically
generalizes Rosen I have talked about
the case remember with lambda min Iife
lashed out very quickly but it was one
demand the our result is only for one
dimension in there so the substitute
case we only have a one-dimensional
result we could not yet get the result
for both multi dimensions we have some
partial results in the paper to address
that and for future we have the multiple
things we're working on asymmetric using
maybe other network measures here
thinking about sensitivity analysis
instead of local can we think about how
the equilibrium changes with respect to
macroscopic changes and the other one
which we're excited about is this idea
of a graph on game and this is basically
an infinite population way of modeling
these large-scale games where you can
still capture the local heterogeneity is
not through the adjacency matrix but
through a graph on function so and that
is something to talk about for later
so with that let me finish thank you
[Applause]
yes I knew that paper but we haven't
made the comparison but yeah I haven't
done yet I know the paper I don't do
that Francesca that's game theoretically
I think a little bit problematic in my
view I don't understand what that means
[Applause]